Southland Royalists came out in droves
to catch a glimpse of Prince Harry as he
arrived at Invercargill Zia port on
Sunday the 10th May as part of his first
ever royal tour of New Zealand the
flame-haired royal was flown and and for
cargo that around 11 a.m. on a Royal NZ
Air Force 75 7200 with Southland LED
flight lieutenant Tom quill curry as his
pilot the Prince was greeted on the
tarmac by Mayor Tim shared bold and
escorted to meet waiting local
dignitaries including night ahoo
representatives deputy mayor Darrin
Ludlow longest-serving City Council in
the old Bonnie face and members of
parliament Sara Dowie Andrea bond
traditional kapa haka was performed as
part of the welcoming ceremony the poem
received a few laughs from Harry and the
crowd before the Prince took some time
to meet one of the city stars Henry the
tuatara the prince was a little
apprehensive about holding the 102 year
old reptile but played it up for the
media with these images promoting the
south an icon throughout the world
that
excited fans packed the airport and
hopes of greeting the prince and shaking
his hand and some fans getting her fits
her clothes
that was a great welcome to the city's
first royal visitor and over 30 years
the contingent also included around 40
police and diplomatic security officials
plus New Zealand Australian and British
media or jousting to get a shot in the
tight space the airport lounge after a
whirlwind stopped the prince in his
entourage left the steward island via
helicopter where he spent his second
night in the country
you